[Music]
on a bust loose on the club roof sucking
throat juice like it's gray goose so
obviously um at the end of season three
we get this like incredible cliffhanger
where the whole band just separates
and so i wanted to first ask you guys
where do we find laszlo and naja at the
top of season four top of season four um
laszlo is
bringing up
baby colin on his own
um before
uh
niger comes comes comes to the front
door and they have their
um
rendezvous you find us we've both been
separated
and laszlo has been at home and i've
been off doing my thing in in london
town and my main thing that i'd like the
audience to know is you find nadja in
maybe the most incredible outfit she's
ever worn at the top
than for
the doll has that magic
um look and it's
that that's the most important thing
you'll need to know really the dress is
incredible
another important thing
concerning that dress is they have such
earth-shattering sex when they do me
that they go straight through the floor
and into the flooded cellar underneath
and that's in the first episode
yeah starting off with a bang honestly
it's honestly like vision board for sex
life for anyone when it comes to laszlo
and naja it's amazing but you mentioned
obviously baby colin robinson who
is just such a brilliant character
because when you think about it like
aren't baby are babies the ultimate
energy vampires and is this colin
robinson at his most powerful no i mean
that's it exactly um
to have him in baby form was such
such a joy even though he wasn't there
like i didn't do any acting uh with the
actors that plays ma i mean the ismart
um
it was just little kids and um
but they were fantastic they all had
dots on their heads so they had to face
the right way then
colin's face is then put onto their
little heads and then that was sort of
how it was done
that's so fascinating naja what was it
like interacting with like kids like
that
oh it was harsher
already
so similar
potato potato i mean no i think um
it was so fun having them and they were
honestly such a little sweet heart
troopers you know like very sweet and
like they were so brave to like come on
these like because it is a very dark set
and you know i forget i've got fangs in
and we're kind we're monsters
essentially and we've got like pale face
paint on and they just like rock up so
confident you know just like chatting
away doing little it's like singing away
and it was just like so
it
even though you know they it wasn't baby
colin robinson and they did all that you
know they've done that in post it was
like
wow it's so funny having a child around
and i had a chainsaw in front of one of
them at one point
and they weren't even in the least kind
of bothered by that it was you know i
was more bothered by the chainsaw than
they were
extraordinary
it's it's like how could your set get
even more fun and then you guys just
answer that question it's honestly
unbelievable i i was wondering how you
actually shot
with baby colin robinson so thank you
for answering that but matt i was also
wondering because you voiced a droid in
book of boba fett
um star wars yeah who's more powerful
baby yoda or baby colin robinson
baby yoda baby yellow will always be
the most powerful
baby in the room i think
i agree even though colin robinson's you
know energy vampire he's the most boring
baby in the room
yoda is the most powerful i think it's
pretty safe to say according to laszlo
and naja how does one rid of an energy
vampire as a human
well i think as
well
to stop yourself being an energy vampire
i think there's some important things
you just have to just kind of notice the
person who you're talking to the second
their eyes begin to kind of glaze and
the second that you
spot that change subjects or
pretend to be dead just do something you
know
startling and i think that is you know
that will stop you from being an energy
vampire
um
well you know like you know like try and
beat them at their own game so you know
we've all been stuck with some energy
vampires if they're boring your socks
off then why don't you start talking
about like soil erosion oh god i'm very
much done yeah start talking about soil
erosion or you know different types of
the different ways you can make uh
glass
yeah or else just
just totally freeze like a
like a zoom
beams you can have yeah
make it fun yeah i think that would be
one way
it's such a joy to see you guys hear irl
in real life because i know i read um
matt that you said that you and natasha
have a very similar sense of humor and i
can like totally see that now and your
chemistry on screen is just it's earth
shattering as you mentioned
how does having a a baby now sort of
affect
naja and laszlo's relationship are their
parenting styles different
no because she's far too busy with
her nightclub she's kind of given it
for me to do solely which is more
interesting because then she can
concentrate on this
amazing idea that is the nightclub while
he
brings up this kid and sort of turns
into a bit of a simon cowell
in the process
um
yeah i mean those two things because
they are a part they can kind of get on
with these two things which
are really sort of interesting and kind
of cool ideas i think but you know it is
it's
always kind of more fun when we're
together doing stuff you know than it is
when we're not
natasha the nightclub is such a i mean
every this this season is so highly
anticipated and the scenarios that you
guys are put in are always so good that
i'm always like how can they come up
with something even funnier and when the
nightclub teaser hit i was like let's go
what like if you had your own vampire
nightclub natasha like what is the
vampire bop like what do vampires get
down to i feel like it's like very high
pitched for me it's like they take all
the best parts of like kate bush
screaming
and
and then mix that with some like cher
and it would be like that but i think in
reality it would be really weird sort of
like
type like music that they'd all be like
losing their minds to
like that's what that's they'd be doing
the drug blood and listening to like the
highest the highest pitched
female screaming type singing that that
that is possible i think and then maybe
some like bon jovi
lesson like then then like you know they
did like they'd like a bit of
evanescence that'd be more sort of like
vampire hot vampire summer would be more
like evanescence and that sort of thing
but yeah i think like kate bush i mean
matt matt and
um one of the writers from series one
tom used to say that when i sang in real
life and as nadu it sounded like kate
moss that had been hit over the head
with a brick
so
well i think that niger is basically
kate bush who's been hit on the head of
the rock
oh [ __ ] sorry
no she's a little kate moss too i mean
those outfits are fire um matt you're a
fantastic musician i love taking my hand
i love summer sun like what bop are you
playing in your vampire nightclub
um
i'm playing
musical theater songs because that's
what little colin robinson likes weirdly
enough
and laszlo really doesn't and there's a
couple of times when he kind of lets
loose with his own songs but he's
he's having to play show tubes because
that's what little colin robinson is
into if you want to try and guess what
mine and matt's
off-screen anthem was for series four i
don't know if you'll be able to get it
was it a show tune or was it like
very modern and matt was the one that
went put this on put this on and then
that was our answer for series four it
was oh oh god it was it was uh oh by
little mix
wait that's such a good song do you guys
sing off because you guys are obviously
you know we've seen laszlo and naja do
musical performances together in like
previous yeah well i don't want to ruin
it more of that
yeah we don't want to ruin it because
you won't have got there yet but there
might be a wedding of sorts i won't say
whose it is but
we are the entertainment at that and
we've and we had to come up with a lot
of filthy songs that
that was some of the
most fun that i've had in any job i've
got to say
yeah
well if you can't tell me what's in the
show i read that paul sims the
showrunner said at one point that you
guys are so good at improvising that
every time he gets into the editing room
they could literally cut the same
episode with the same story with
entirely different dialogue can you tell
us like is there something that ended up
maybe on the cutting room floor that's
not in the episode that you guys like
sang together or did together for this
season or maybe past seasons there
there's times when tash and i will come
up with a very sort of british reference
just to
screw with them just to see whether
they're going to put it in or not and
they have done in the past much to our
sort of shock other than that you know
there are times when we go quite low
down um and i always think myself
there's no way that's going to go in and
of course it doesn't but it's great fun
to do was there like a specific moment
even from past seasons that you guys
just couldn't stop laughing because it's
like like i'm literally just laughing
out loud on my couch watching it
it depends how cold it is if if for
instance if it's just speaking
personally if it's cold then um
i don't normally corpse because i'm too
cold or if i'm up high because i'm
terrified of heights then i won't corpse
because i'm too terrified
um
yeah they're the times when
i can't
i'm just unable to corpse
well i think
for me i think from the times where we
corpse the most is when
me and matt are doing our talking heads
together because we you know you'll get
into like you'll do maybe you'll have to
sit and do a bunch of them over a number
of you know over a whole day
and we'd start you know just saying
stuff to make each other laugh or like
matt would always start his talking we
always start to get as if matt was
saying something already so he'd you
know say the tail end of a sentence
which is absolutely ridiculous and then
we'd have to
head and that would always be like wow
well another thing
another thing that we always wanted to
do was start a talking head but as if
i'm about to say something
and then tash would come straight in so
it would be like
and then she comes in
and uh and you do that every single time
and i don't know whether they've put
those in i hope they have because
that would make me laugh i think
i would hope that they would put that in
what makes me laugh the most and we have
to talk about this is the tour de force
from season two that is jackie daytona i
mean the humans and the mortals want to
know matt like is jackie daytona coming
back
i have no idea because we don't know
anything about what happens in the show
until the first
draft of the first script is
sent to our
sent to our hotels and that's the first
time you know that we have any idea of
what's going on i mean for me that was
such fun to do
for loads of reasons you know one you
know i got to
literally cross swords with um luke
skywalker which
i never thought i'd be doing that in any
world so
yeah you know it was a huge kind of
thrill you know and i'm just like really
sort of
quietly happy you know that everybody
you know that it sort of worked and
everybody liked it
would you want him to come back because
i there's a moment where you say i'm
just a regular human guy in the bar and
i lost it on my couch i don't know why
that line was so good to me what is it
like playing laszlo
playing jackie daytona and did you pull
from any pop culture references like
what did you look to for inspiration for
that character all that i kind of wanted
to do was do an exaggerated version of
laszlo so he was even more like laszlo
when he was jackie daytona and his
disguise was a toothpick which is a
fantastic idea i don't know who came up
with that it's probably steph but
such a funny idea so
the joke being that he's not disguised
at all and he's you know and is
exactly the same he's got some stupid
costume on you know but other than that
he is basically you know basically
laszlo and i just upped laszlo so he
would be more lazlow when he was uh
jackie daytona natasha have you ever
thought because nadja is just i mean
i gotta give you your flowers she's just
so iconic oh and i know that that word
is so overused but you really are like
you're so brilliant um have you ever
thought of like what nausea's secret
identity sort of jackie daytona version
would be
god yeah i haven't i mean i have always
thought it'd be really fun to do an
episode or a storyline where where both
nadja and lazlo go on the run in
disguise
and you know maybe i'm jack daytona and
he's jackie daytona or something like
that like i always thought that would be
a really fun thing to see you know it's
always i think it's always fun when you
see these characters
in the real world you know outside
trying to sort of
you know i've i loved we did an episode
where i got to interact with them sean's
wife who's played by marissa wenika and
like that was so much fun you know just
like amongst these like staten island
ladies that was incredible so yeah
anything like that yeah they're great
improvisers those two
oh yeah patches
yeah those two are really really good
improvisers so it's always a huge joy to
work with those two because you know
you're gonna get something
i love seeing sean i love seeing gregor
like we need housewives of staten island
vampire version stat oh yeah
the bachelor in in this season which i'm
super stoked about i wanted to ask you
guys
because
laszlo and naja are such like vision
board goals and lifelong partners like
according to you guys
how does one lock down a lifelong
partner i mean i think it's just like
literally just committing to the idea
and then just being like
i mean you probably have to get a bit of
brain damage to get to this point
because it's literally like they just so
blindly love each other and are so
attracted to each other no matter what
the other one's doing no matter how
stupid they're being they're just like
oh yes please
so i don't
i i think you probably do just have to
be alive for a few hundred years or
something to get to that point but yeah
they just they just always look for the
good in each other they're always so
into each other it doesn't matter it's
like you may be you may have embarrassed
me so much you've done something so
stupid but ultimately you're my one and
i love and
it's so fun to play because matt was
saying earlier you know like in comedies
and sitcoms it's quite often that you
know it's like the two the main couple
are sort of arguing a lot and getting on
each other's nerves but it's so fun to
play two people that no matter what
they've done you know they're just like
oh you know so horny for each other the
whole time and you never expected by it
yeah and it's endearing to see a sort of
male character like in laszlo be so
luxurious sort of towards is like
i love that matt what's your what's your
advice on like according to laszlo how
to lock down a lifelong partner
no it's just
um
i mean it's the same as same as what
some is what tash has said i mean it's
very very rare
in comedy to see um
a couple not be
annoyed by to one another you know and
be on the edge of kind of breaking up
that seems to be you know what we're
kind of used to with
comedy couples um
so it's a real kind of breath of fresh
air when you have
two characters that it doesn't you know
like tasha's you know it doesn't matter
where they've been what they've just
done who they've done it to
they can't wait to get back in the sack
and i just think you know that's kind of
cool and it's different and
it's almost something really new you
know
it is so new i i think that's why it's
people love it because it's like this
rare love
this everlasting love that will never go
away um something to aspire to
natasha i was reading that you said
after season one that you totally
said bye to everyone as if you were
never gonna see them ever again we're
like bye i was so nice working with you
and you never and here we are
you know at the brink of season four and
the show is just it's so beloved by so
many
did this question is for the both of you
but i want to hear from you first did
you know has this show just totally
surpassed your expectations so in the uk
you know shows that we have like on
average six episodes a season and
things don't usually go beyond sort of
three seasons max usually two so we did
ten episodes in season one and i was
like well
then you know like that there's no way
i'll they'll want more of this like who
was going to want more of this so yeah i
truly was like peace out love you ass
you're right this is
catchy catch you on the flippity flip um
and it was
so i was like oh wow we're doing a
second season so yeah to be at the point
where we're at season four
and you know we're gonna be doing a
season five and six it is like
yeah it's
wild it's wild i i it's so insane and
lovely and
you know i hope that i hope people still
like it and still you know
still get it's still giving people what
you know they love about it so yeah it's
um
it's i don't know what to say it's like
two thumbs up five out of five counts of
popcorn cans of popcorn what are we
talking about
no i mean
yeah i mean that's completely it wasn't
after the first it wasn't even after the
first season that i thought that i
thought that after the pilot i remember
because we shot the pilot in los angeles
and i remember at the end of that
thinking right well this will go one or
two ways they'll either
get on board with it or they'll think
why the hell have they made this when
that film is so good
why would i want to watch this and that
was that was all that i was kind of
thinking i was thinking it'll either
work or it absolutely won't and that's
the end of that
i certainly
didn't think you know that five years
later
going into a fifth one you know that was
the last thing that was going through my
mind
back then and you both
congratulations of course on the
upcoming seasons and beautiful answer
and you both have like such
sort of illustrious careers where does
what we do in the shadows like stand for
you in your career
um well i just think it's
it's such an important
part of
what i've done because
for a couple of reasons artistically
because it's so sort of freeing to do
you can do whatever you want in this
show you can try whatever you want
there's no
you know there's no one kind of holding
you back at any point it's actually
quite the opposite they're encouraging
you just to sort of try things out and
it's quite rare to be able to do that
and to be a you know to be able to do
that for five you know for five years is
such a bonus and you know i'm very kind
of humbled with it because like i say
it's a rarity
and just the fact you know that it's
open doors for
you know
a bunch of other things i mean i've said
it before but it's
a moderately successful show in the uk
i've just come back from los angeles
where
i noticed that
it was more than a moderately successful
show i don't think i will i don't think
i'll ever ever do a show like this again
like i don't it doesn't feel like oh you
know like sometimes you do a part in
something that you think oh this is kind
of similar to something else i've done
or you know probably will do again
whereas this show it's like you will
never ever ever play a
mad vampire woman who owns a nightclub
who like
you know who's like
the husband is is coaching a child with
the head of an adult like you know some
of the sometimes we me and matt are on
set and we're like wait okay so there's
the baron he's he's half a body and then
there's the fire who's like in in a car
k van's dressed in like american
football where
again
up with a rope
um
kristin's looks like kristen looks like
a nun and mark is like feeding and
you're like
this will never happen again this has
never happened before and it will never
happen again so yeah it's
an unbelievably rare sort of gem of a
show and
yeah
long may long may she long may she reign
the show is definitely a she oh a
thousand percent and
it's a clear depiction of um you know
what heaven looks like
yeah
i hope so
that's literally what you described we
obviously see you guys go to atlantic
city so looking ahead if you were
writers of the show you know what's a
destination that you would love um all
these characters to go to
it's so boring i've said it before but
i'd love them to come to london or
europe you know or cyprus or greece you
know somewhere somewhere in europe i
think would be would be really really
fun i just think because so we're all
from there so maybe it's kind of me
selfishly as an actor being like i'd
love to like
you know for like to come here and see
what it would be like to film on the
streets of london and like you know do
some vampiric stuff because also
you know like london and europe you know
especially england it's such an old
country and they have so much history
here so i think it'd be really fun to
play on that history and and
with those you know with the you know
the queen and like everything like that
i just think it would be houses of
parliament big ben yeah all that sort of
very very ancient stuff that we have
here in the uk i think would be really
fun
for the vampires to sort of play on that
and with that
and selfishly be yeah really lovely that
i could get all of my friends to visit
the set
[Laughter]
no i
agree with that because it makes
absolute sense because like tash says
you know they're all you know the
the sort of leading characters are all
from are all from europe um so
for them to go back home i mean because
the reason why they're in
staten island is because they don't want
to go back home so to basically face
um
their peers you know is always going to
be fun i think guillermo is a such an
icon to me
um but
because naja and laszlo don't have
familiars is there someone in the world
whether it's a celebrity or public
figure or just someone in your life that
you would love to be your characters
familiar
um well they have had families but they
just they just kill them um
they can't be trusted to have
a familiar
but um tash and i was saying the other
day that when haley joel osman when he
came on set he he would be such a
perfect familiar yeah
but he wasn't amazing familiar but he um
he's got zombif what happened to him
again he he was a zom we we took him to
benny and then he turned him into a
zombie everyone can come back
yeah exactly yeah he was great i think i
mean
personally you know
on a on a very selfish unrealistic level
i'd love someone like catherine o'hara
or or um rupaul or cher to come and be
elon musk
he'd be good for me
elon musk could buy the vampiric council
and that'll be
no no no he's got to come to us with no
money
that's true
my search for new wife has not been
going so great i am not a creep i'm just
a very ancient warrior who wishes to
marry you come back
whoops the end of the last season ends
on like a major cliffhanger
the band you know breaks up so i feel
like it's important to sort of set the
stage for everybody at home
where do we find guillermo and nandor at
the top of season four
well a whole year has gone by
and they've been separated and
guillermo has gone to london with naja
and she's been with the council there
and while there he's discovered himself
and discovered new
um
you know uh abilities that you know he
had and asking some questions and um and
then we find ourselves back at the house
and we meet up again with nandor uh
who's on a
on a worldwide tour um and then we find
that we are now dealing with an infant
baby colin and we pick up there okay man
where where do we find nandor at the top
of this season
um
unsurprisingly back in the house
with everyone else
but he's yeah he's gone on his kind of
eat pray love journey and come back none
the wiser i'd say which is pretty pretty
nandor of him
um but he's got a new toy to play with
his uh
his genie in his lamp or his gin
um
played by the wonderful anub desai
gotta stop giving him shout outs because
he doesn't talk about me in interviews
and um
he is a wonderful actor it's just
egomaniac
um and singer he's a great singer and
singer incredible singer wow um did he
sing anything on set like in between he
didn't he actually
he sung
he didn't sing till like because he was
there for the whole season so thank god
he was a nice dude because i don't know
how i would have put up with him
otherwise i was like man how many
episodes are you in
like eight really
am i even in eight episodes
[Laughter]
he's like uh he's coming for landor's
gig
he's coming fernando's gig nah no he's
not gonna have it
but he yeah he basically he used to be
he was in american idol for a bit
he got pretty far on american idol
and then
yeah he started singing one night late
at night um i think we'd had a few
beverages
i think we were
at natasha's apartment or something and
he just picks up one of her hair brushes
and starts singing
and it's amazing
and we're just like this is incredible
man and he finished the singing man
we're all cheering
i was like you could have done that 10
weeks ago man i would have been nicer to
you
[Laughter]
harvey when you say
you know i don't want to give anything
away but in that first episode when the
gin is there and you're like you can't
say that
nandor says something i died last night
oh yeah
yeah it was so good um so caveman what i
especially love so much about like the
start of this season is i actually used
to work on the bachelor and we get to
see
nandor sort of play the bachelor in a
way i was wondering what is nandor's
type that's a very good question i mean
i don't even know i don't think anyone
does he doesn't even know
but i guess that's good that he doesn't
know because he keeps
trying new types you know
i mean ever i guess everyone has a type
i think he's coming to the realization
that his type is you know
harvardgian flavored perhaps whatever
flavor guillermo might be i don't know
harvey's blushing right now
spicy nut no it's natural
rouge um from guillermo's perspective
harvey you know what do you what do you
think nandor's type is like what type of
partner does nandor need i mean someone
who
um
who can tolerate all his like you know
he he just goes on adventures all the
time and changes his mind about things
easily
um someone who's patient
um
with him and uh and his needs because i
feel like nandor has gotten everything
he's wanted you know he's pillaged
villages
he's uh he's taking over
uh but he's a real softie so he like
needs to be cuddled and like needs to be
um and sometimes babied you know like in
a way where it's like someone who like
is there like every beck and call but
also someone with the good heart because
uh
uh he kind of wears his hardness sleeve
nandor is so loving when he is in love i
remember when he got gail and just like
completely was smitten by her and a
little bit of a jealousy from guillermo
in that moment just like damn it her
head when they're playing kickball
uh
but the idea that uh he is he's a lover
you know as much as he's a fighter he's
a warrior but he's a lover and i feel
like he needs to have someone who
reflects that for him i was actually
reading a really interesting uh thing
that you said kavan that nandor actually
wears his hair like on the side of his
face
uh to sort of portray like his
insecurity and ha or his you know how he
is sort of hiding and i thought that was
like really interesting to read even
though i selfishly would love to see
nandor just rock the man bun always so i
was talking to matt and natasha and they
told me that um
there's a wedding
this season and i was wondering what you
guys could tell me about that like is
nandor getting married um i would love
to tell you all about that however i i
think that
that comes on the spoiler alert and i
don't want to be the one to start
spoiling
things and alerting people to you know
spoiled things
um
i don't know can we mention the wedding
i think we announced it at
fyc laszlo and
um guillermo
get married
oh my god
he's gonna kill me
oh my god we're about the same height
yes we are
[Laughter]
and
that's it that's all it took so
and colin robinson gets to watch
uh colin robinson just the most
brilliant character on television um
cayman i love that you just slipped into
into laszlo's voice i was wondering
because you you really are truly so
brilliant and nandor have you ever
slipped into nandor's accent in real
life and like did it ever come out in
sort of unexpected situation
well during sex you mean
no i did not mean that
um i i just i feel like it's such a fun
voice that i i would find myself sort of
just like dropping it in random
conversation
does that happen with me
nando's voice is is so different to my
own voice
i feel like when people
hear me speak they're kind of
disappointed i don't speak like nando
and i i feel like a bit of a letdown
like oh my god it's so great to meet you
yes thank you very much it's happy to
meet you too
would you like a selfie you know what i
mean i i feel like that's that's more of
a fun ride for them than for me to go oh
thanks very much yeah it's great it's
like why is he talking like that i don't
like this
i like the nandor voice you're not my
voice well you can't have it
what
but yeah it does feel like that because
everyone like you know guillermo sounds
like harvey and
matt sounds like jackie daytona and
natasha kind of sounds like
nadja you know just maybe a bit less of
a greek accent but it's same you know
she still has that register and you know
of course mark sounds like colin sounds
like mark sounds like
[Laughter]
i would say mark sounds the closest to i
mean i would also say like for me like i
don't talk like in guillermo's level all
the time so when people meet me i'm like
literally they're like because guillermo
talks with the soft voice you know he's
not soft spoken and when when nandor
does them in last season when he does
the guillermo boys he nailed it because
it's very soft and it's very you know
the way he did it you know
he doesn't mimic someone you know and
not everyone's it was like all right but
that's you know that's like this is like
hi my name is
yeah but uh but kevin's also a master of
like a million voices so like i would if
you already heard his nand or like i
wouldn't waste you know your time with
the voice already hurt you should hear
all the other voices you can do well
there you go okay man i mean i can't
move on until
i mean yes you can no no
come on
no no not got it got it okay start your
specific wait so everybody stay tuned
for that i'm so excited for that um what
is also really exciting about this
upcoming season is the vampire nightclub
and i know that guillermo is obviously
you know vampire slayer extraordinaire
he's also like extraordinary bodyguard i
was wondering harvey like is guillermo
the bouncer to the not is he but like
how would guillermo be as a bouncer how
would he fare as a bouncer of a
nightclub
um i think he would be
it would be like a lot of power for him
and maybe go a little power hungry um
and he probably let all the all like the
people who wouldn't traditionally get
into a club in uh just because he would
see himself in them and be like you with
the glasses in the back who's shy come
come forward come inside uh but he does
get uh he does get a position at the
nightclub this season um
that he asked for uh which may or could
be part of a master plan
i love that and that moment that you're
dancing in the teaser is so fun and i've
read a lot extensively about the
backstory that you've built for
guillermo um so i could totally see him
sort of just letting in you know the
underdog and not like the cool popular
kids you uh harvey it i just want to say
as a latina like it truly means so much
to me in in the most genuine way because
i know that a lot of roles that you've
auditioned for weren't written for you
and you've really made people rethink
what characters should be and look like
and um even even um having authentic
bunuelos in the scene where you know
you're shooting guillermo with his mom
and i know that you were making them
right up until the camera started and um
i i wanted to know
what from your what from your
authenticity in your life were you able
to bring into guillermo season four
because i know he's sort of becoming
more and more i don't want to say you
but you're sort of really crafting him
to be like this awesome unique badass
well thank you i mean thank you that
that means a lot um just because we
could say to a rule in the face but
representation matters and it matters to
be seen and it matters to feel seen um
and so even down to the bunuelos where
um
i couldn't live with myself knowing that
there was like a different type of gun
yellow because there's different kinds
you know there's different countries
i know yeah and so when when it was on
script it wasn't specific that it was a
mexican umbrella so we had you know our
prop master who's amazing and fantastic
just googled it was like when yellows
and the first ones that came up were
like from south america
and they were not the same shape and
form of a mexican when you were low so
when we were shooting that scene i just
remember that i was like what are those
like they're
like we would never have those in the
mexican house but like that's not what
we were so we were like just get flowers
with you guys get some sugar some oil
and we were like in the kitchen
literally up until the minute and i was
like yeah just let them dry put the
cinnamon roll because it matters and
people notice people notice them in the
background that they were the right wing
yeah no one else would have cared no one
else would have been like oh yeah
whatever it's my background um but
you're a hero
it's the small things uh but then it's
important this season i'm really proud
of is uh bringing that dynamic of having
um that mexican culture and happen in
the household with the family uh we do
get to uh meet our family uh on
guillermo's side and um and we're
excited about that and paul's already
spoken about this but um we're excited
to meet them and and and seeing that
dynamic that people are going to relate
to like yes see that's how because the
second one when you meet his mom and the
way that he says amma
to his mom and people were like i say am
i like no one knows that because it's
hard to describe someone who doesn't
because we google translate mom it's
madre you know and no one says and
sometimes if you're being serious like
mother you know but like you know you
say amma it's like it's a
true endearment you know it's like a mom
and so that was something that was so
subtle but people picked up on so you
see a lot of more of those little things
verbally sprinkled in uh which makes me
happy for uh for the audience to see it
makes me so i'm dominican so i get it
because our empanadas are pastelitos and
because i'm from the caribbean i'm just
waiting for walter mercado to make an
appearance oh my god
how epic is that he's so epic he could
be a wizard he could be a wizard she
wants honestly
harvey let's make it happen let's make
it happen
if guillermo finally became a vampire
how would it sort of change the dynamic
between guillermo and nandor i'd love to
hear from both of you because obviously
everyone's sort of like you know
wanting to know i mean a vampire
how would it change the dynamic i mean
okay what do you think like how did that
play out
if what if the dynamic if if if uh if
guillermo became a vampire and we were
front
right
how would that dynamics work
i was i was when you said you were
dominican i remember that i'd done a
film in dominican republic and um
i got introduced to brugal lienda yeah
i
can't drink man
i have brugal and president in my house
oh yeah yeah oh my god that was the one
because the all the
the booze shops would turn into like uh
a club like you'd buy the booze there
from the
well from the liquor store and then
anyway uh back to the uh guillermo
nandor dynamic
i mean i can't imagine
i can't imagine him being a vampire i
mean
i feel like if he became a vampire then
his
wish would come true and
it might then turn into a nightmare but
having another vampire in the house i
mean sure why not it will definitely you
know if they decide that's what they
want to do with it
then
they'll do it for a good reason which
would be it'll be hilarious
but why that would be
i mean
i don't know i think there still needs
to be a kind of
master servant dynamic between
uh guillermo and um hernando and that
you know they're coming up with more
ingenious ways of
maintaining that even though
guillermo is now a vampire slayer you
know
it's terrifying to see them when they do
come you know head to head because i
mean guillermo is powerful in his own
way with the van helsing inside of him
so when they do have these battles like
they're not budging and like even last
season where it was like back to back in
his in his bedroom where like at the
last minute with the crucifix and his
face and then nandor tells him he passed
the test and that was the reason that he
stood down yeah pretty terrifying to see
that he's just as powerful as nandor is
he's a vampire and he's just human with
that housing blood running through his
veins and if you have to layer a vampire
on top of that does that elevate him
to a level where he's unstoppable you
know what i mean yeah very terrifying to
be in that what happens what happens
when the van helsing blood meets the
vampire blood something right it's got
to go down you don't know it's going to
go down it's going to go down i have a
last question for you but just because
you brought up van gaal saying uh harvey
have you thought of like talking to van
helsing's ghost like
i don't know hugh jackman you know what
i mean like have you thought open to
like you know any slayer from the past
hugh jackman buffy like just like would
be quoted like buffy like come out of
retirement and be like i heard you need
my help you know just like i don't know
like some guy was me doing something
check out please forgive me uh but just
the idea that i'm always open to have
somebody come and train guillermo in
whatever sense like with antonio
banderas who's a
who's also a vampire uh part of the
vampire world uh you know with van
helsing he jackman with uh
you know simon shower mercado yeah
you guys i i would love that too and i
just can't wait to see where your story
goes you guys were talking about the
power dynamics it is so fun to watch you
both sort of have fun
and and you're both just so good at it
where do you want to see guillermo and
nandor end up as harvey and kayvan like
personally i don't want them to ever end
up anywhere
i want them to keep searching for
whatever it is they're searching for
uh i think once they end up
then you know
the end will be up
and uh that will be that but
yeah it's always the journey really not
a destination for me anyway
but uh there's there's a lot of gas left
in the the nando guillermo nandermo
tank i'd say
so we'll see man
no no same i just wanted to be happy
wherever they they end up going to be
happy i feel they're all searching for
what you know brings them happiness and
and uh and i just would like them all to
be happy especially with mandela
i love it it's the best wedding hashtag
ever
oh my god
you